let's talk about the State of the Union
in terms of the unit itself and not
Economic Policy whatever because we have
a story from the post-millennial man
woman charged in plot to attack Maryland
power grid okay that's kind of freaky
because you know we we work out of
Maryland we'll be leaving soon with the
new studio being constructed and
everything but um yeah when I saw a
story like this this is like what the
30-something uh power grid or
substations that were were either
unplanned to be attacked or were
attacked we saw it happen I mean all
over the US people have been for some
reason attacking the power grid I I
don't know why or whatever they're
saying I guess the reason for this is
that they were racists I'm not kidding
they said they were racists and that's
why they wanted to do it for some kind
of like racist ideology or white
supremacy or something but I'm just
thinking I'm just thinking like they're
accelerationists they want maybe a civil
war to break out I said it Tim didn't uh
yeah you can't drink I didn't say it no
but I'm like the state of the union is
west coast states are Banning gas cars
was it what my Wyoming or Montana
Banning electric cars was it Montana
there's Montana yeah it was Montana
Montana you can pull it but you've got
Oklahoma now they did that bill where
they're banning uh child sex changes and
protesters showed up demanding the right
to give children sex changes you have
some states that are Banning abortion
outright While others are creating uh
laws to Grant abortion to the point of
birth the bifurcation like the state of
the union is hyperpolarization chaos and
conflict Joe Biden's gonna come out
tonight everything's great
there's nothing to worry about and it's
like it's like the Titanic hit the
iceberg and then everyone's like what
was that shake it's like nothing's
happening everything's good we are on
course meanwhile his son's negotiating
foreign business deals to send Louisiana
natural gas to China make them some
money because I'm telling you that the
the Titanic hit the iceberg and the
bidens and the Democratic establishment
and many Republicans as well have
started loading up at everything they
can in lifeboats and they're getting
ready to jump ship Wyoming proposed uh
Banning electric cars and the big
argument was that the infrastructure
can't handle it it costs them more to
make electric cars work in their very
rural State I mean it's an Evidence of
how different it's like there are two
countries here there's one Multicultural
democracy and there's another one that's
much more tied to like constitutional
republic can we just coexist can we live
in parallel worlds no yo I'm sorry man I
do not see how and and people tell me
I'm wrong and maybe I am but people will
come in and be like ah Tim's crazy we're
thinking civil war is coming and it's
like okay you're by all mean by all
means please please I'd love to be wrong
because I just don't understand how
there can be one country where one state
allows
child sex change operations
when the child has been taken from
another state
and as a sanctuary that's the point
Texas is moving to ban this California
is calling it a sanctuary I don't
understand how a country can exist where
it's legal to murder someone in Oregon
but illegal basically everywhere else
and that's the story I don't know if you
guys saw about the death tourism you've
got a doctor saying come he's telling
people to come to his practice and he
will give you death pills it's like yeah
that's murder
you know and we're looking at medical
assistance and dying in Canada Canada
actually has a moratorium right now
uh on mentally ill medical assistance
and deaf that ends in uh in in about one
month meaning they it actually says in
the government website you do not need
to be terminal in order to get medical
assistance and dying in Canada you can
be just mentally ill and they will if
you ask kill you
there's a guy in Oregon who is saying
and he's brought people from other
states and killed them and I'm just like
look man if it's it's one thing to have
republicanism where it's like the laws
are different in different states but uh
not when it's like one state would allow
you to take a child from from a
different state and then castrate them
he's like as sooner or later I guess
I'll put it this way
the Jeff younger story was that his kids
were taken from Texas
to California where California is a
gender affirmation Sanctuary they will
not comply with law enforcement to
return the child who's been taken if
they're going to get sterilized and
castrated
so what happens
someone takes a kid from Texas against
their parents wishes tied up in the
courts the feds won't do anything about
it what happens well I'll tell you this
is someone our Texas Rangers going to go
to California to get that kid back no
are the feds going to do it not under
Biden under a Donald Trump presidency
maybe the fed's going to get that kid
back and then you have to think about
the inverse what if a family is from
California and the state is going to you
know that this kid's going to get
castrated or whatever and so the parent
flees to Texas where it's illegal is
California going to send State Police to
Texas to get that kid back I don't think
so under Biden they might so that just
says to me that we're looking at the
country has split so far into they are
they are at odds to a point where
there's no reconciliation and depending
on who the president is you will get
action in either direction
well if we were economically stable I
think it would be that we would be able
to co-exist even with things like this
weird like killing killing people and
and changing children's gender but in
economic instability that's that's when
people are more willing to take the law
into their own hands if they're
suffering if they're starving if their
families have threat of death then I
mean what choice do you have your
government's failed you at that point
um which again pisses me off that Biden
hasn't talked about the Federal Reserve
since he's been in office and why we're
going to bankrupt as a country I know I
need him the state so you're talking
earlier about the domestic State of the
Union this is all like domestic stuff
now internationally the state of the
union is the liberal economic order is
turning into the new world order at
least this is my ideal thing uh like
what's happening is a new world order is
being created whether or not it's bricks
which is the Chinese Russian India
Brazil and uh South Africa South African
Coalition or if it's the liberal World
Order which is like England France
Germany United States it's or both of
them together if it's Schwab's corporate
Global dominance that he wants to do
where corporations controls the world or
uh I don't know but I think that that is
our state of the union forward-facing
globally is that the liberal economic
order has the opportunity to establish a
new world order based on statehood
instead of uh central control
I generally like when states have
autonomy over their own lives right it
is challenging to see how you navigate
inconsistencies but I don't like the
idea of seeding power to a federal
government and I'd rather have the
states it becomes extremely complicated
I always have felt strongly especially
about like children's rights issues a
lot of law basically treats children
like they're the property of their
parents which in many respects of course
they are they're under their
guardianship but in these cases
especially where your parents who don't
agree on such fundamental levels as to
you know should we or should we let our
child transition genders or not it
becomes very difficult to see and the
idea that uh the most common form of
kidnapping from what I understand in the
data that I last looked at is Parental
abduction when a parent who's going
through divorce takes their kid would by
having such uh such a splintered culture
and Identity or understanding of
morality make that even worse going
forward but let's talk about
republicanism and let's talk about the
limits the idea being that each state
enforces its own laws let's say you uh
share a house with three other room
mates and each have a bedroom
and one of your roommates opens his
window and starts letting strangers come
into the house they go in the kitchen
start eating your food they're in their
living room watching TV and you're like
who are you people how did you get in
here and they're like we live here now
and then you're like yeah no no no no no
you're not allowed to come in here oh no
he let us in that's what California's
doing California quite literally is a
sanctuary State and they're allowing
people to illegally enter to a certain
degree offering them resources and then
these people use California as their
entry point and then go through other
words don't get me wrong they're still a
legally Crossing in Arizona and Texas
and the federal government's doing
nothing about it but California is
abusing this these ideas they're using
it to fluff their their population
numbers their their their census numbers
so they actually had I think in the
previous in the 2010s they had an extra
congressional seat and an extra
Electoral College vote because they
allowed non-citizens into the country
so yeah no we can't the federal
government needs to have laws that
everyone says okay these are the basic
rules you can't non-citizens can't be
coming in because then they go around
everywhere otherwise we we do what we
put up border checkpoints on the
highways between states we can't do that
people from different states yeah well
what's frustrating for me is that
conservatives are so reluctant to use
federal power right even when they have
it and it's it's honestly Un-American
like Washington short after becoming
president he you know quelled a
rebellion with Force like that is a very
American thing to do but for some reason
us as conservatives we've become so
enamored with states rights and so
scared of you know using government to
reach our ends that we're just getting
mowed over by the Dems who are doing
that exact thing right so we have to
step up and when we have power we have
to be able to use it and be willing to
use it or else we're going to lose our
country we're going to be serfs in a
country that's run by you know power
hungry woke my minorities it's going to
be insane it's all going to be you know
affirmative action hiring and all of
that nut stuff what would be an example
of using the law in your favor so I
think DeSantis is a great example of
doing this at the state level and I hope
that if you know his president
presidential Ambitions if he does become
the candidate that he'll be able to do
that the federal level but the way he
pulled the liquor license right when
that family style restaurant was having
a drag show for kids
um with minors present so doing things
like that I think you know a lot of
conservatives will look at that and
they'll be like oh my goodness he's
using big government like we don't do
that what if they you know we set a
standard that they're going to later use
against us we can't think like that
because I really do think you know to
your point about Civil War time is of
the essence we're losing our country so
we have to take a final stand and be
willing to get our hands dirty thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time